le sceau de l'elysée a posé sur un
cadran l'ip
c'est un peu l'histoire de la marque qui
se perpétue le général de gaulle a vécu
son propre modèle
emmanuel macron a choisi lui d'en faire
un objet emblématique du made in france
comme une centaine d'autres produits qui
seront distribués par l'elysée parmi les
produits qui étaient présentes et il a
vu cette montre dauphine cette montre
libre dauphine qui est d'ailleurs
magnifique un cadre magnifique mais
surtout qui porte le bracelet bleu blanc
rouge quelques jours finalement après
que la france a été championne du monde
donc il a semble-t-il près ce qu'on me
dit vraiment beaucoup apprécié le
produit il l'a mis à son poignet il a
dit voilà la montre que je vais porter
cet été vendu à l'occasion des journées
du patrimoine ou offertes par la suite
aux autres de marc reçu à l'elysée la
libre dauphine version présidentielle a
déjà été fabriquées à une centaine
d'exemplaires
renouant ainsi une fois de plus avec
l'histoire du pays
une partie quelque part de l'histoire de
france parce que les montres lip était
sur les poignées des poilus en 14 était
voilà c'est ça une belle marque
ces trois lettres je trouvais même ça
presque trop court et finalement l'ip
les gens s'en rappellent trois lettres
définitivement inscrite dans le
patrimoine horloger français